[Musique]
marie maude on a vu dans l'actualité
cette semaine le début du procès
criminel des employés à la suite de la
tragédie de lac mégantic et notre
collègue s'est lui fournir beaucoup
enquêté sur ce sujet et le découvert
autre chose sur ce pseudo avocat qui
avait approché plein de familles
endeuillées celui qu'on a surnommé le
vautour de lac mégantic
mais avant de parler les nouvelles
révélations
on va regarder un aperçu de son enquête
de l'hiver dernier pour nous c'est une
des catastrophes ferroviaires les plus
meurtrières au canada ce qui s'est passé
après la tragédie est aussi un drame
très loin de là aux etats unis les
avocats se prépare une course vient de
commencer
ils se sont rués sur ces gens sans même
les connaître c'est criminel
ici aux etats unis c'est un cas
classique fric
on nous a convoqués à une réunion à
savoir si on voulait faire partie d'un
recours collectif ont recours
intellectuelle que quelqu'un qui venu me
voir me disant madame aimeriez vous que
la même chose arrive à une autre maman
ce quine qui veut nous voir
ben je pense que c'est m garcia del
edwards pratique le droit depuis presque
un demi-siècle au texas
il a ruiné garcia à l'oeil depuis
longtemps c'est un homme très persuasif
il doit l'être pour parvenir à ses fins
les chasseurs d'ambulances le sont tous
garcia et sa firme ne ferait aucun
travail d'ordre juridique
ils sont souvent les premiers sur les
lieux d'une catastrophe où qu'elles
surviennent dans le monde
il trouve des cas qu'ils revendent en
quelque sorte à des cabinets d'avocats
c'est illégal et immoral ce label
edwards tout mais pour moi ces gens
exploitent le deuil et la détresse comme
si les victimes n'étaient que des
morceaux de viande dans l'état de
moucher car oui les garcia est bel et
bien l'homme qui a convaincu ginette
cameron d'engager des poursuites aux
états unis
au total des proches de 40 des 47
disparus ont signé avec ces mêmes
avocats vent s'est fait vraiment poussé
à dire nous sommes là pour faire signer
pour vous représenter faites nous
confiance
les victimes ont fait confiance
rassuré par la présence d'un avocat
québécois hans mercier
j'ai été contacté par les deux banques
américains parce que les écouter ça nous
prend un procureur local
oui les gars y'a vous n'avez pas
rencontré
c'est possible nous avons tenté d'en
savoir plus sur la firme garcia des
recherches dans les registres officiels
du texas révèle que la firme a été
enregistrée le 13 ou 2013 soit un mois
après la tragédie et après le dépôt de
la première poursuite
la firme est au nom de maria mairie
garcia se meurt et garcia
l'avocat de la firme je ne me dit rien
du tout willy et mary garcia nous répond
unis et nous appellent ni à nos nombreux
courriels les familles représentées par
garcia et son groupe ont payé pour la
plupart des honoraires de 40% les
chiffres a fait sursauter le juge
québécois chargé d'approuver le
règlement à faire aux victimes 40
millions c'est parcours et à boîte à
malle plus vite les autres la seule la
firme garcia aurait reçu entre 10 et 15
millions de dollars selon notre
évaluation c'est chacun on est une
machine à faire du profit
sylvie dans un cas pareil qui doit
protéger le public est ce que c'est le
bar le bar où serait le travail des
avocats
c'est comme ça qu'il protège le public
est dense que s'il ya eu des signaux
d'alarmé mais le barreau ne pas réagi
dès les premiers jours des avocats
américains se sont précipités sur les
lieux de la tragédie à lac mégantic
on les a vus à la télé attirer des
clients pour ensuite les inciter à
entamer des poursuites aux états unis
le barreau était pourtant sur les lieux
mais n'a pas senti le besoin
d'intervenir
personne ne se soit la mairesse que ce
soit certains citoyens sinistrés en
deuil on ne porte plus de téléphones en
a pas eu de drapeaux rouges en âmes on
aurait besoin de vous et pas de réaction
un an plus tard quand apparaissent des
signes que quelque chose ne tourner pas
rond
le barreau est informé que des avocats
et utilise des méthodes de
sollicitations dérangeante que des
résidents en pleurs se disent victimes
de harcèlement
avec le recul le barreau reconnaît à
contrecoeur n'avoir prier vu du danger
qui guettait les victimes
c'est lorsqu'on a visionné a comme
plusieurs personnes au québec
votre reportage où là on en a on a
constaté qu'il y avait des gens qui
avaient besoin d'information avait
besoin du support à nos révélations ont
fait vivement réagir la ministre de la
justice mme stéphanie vallée geste rare
dans une lettre envoyée le jour de notre
reportage
elle qualifie de fort préoccupant les
faits rapportés par enquêtes et rappelle
aux barreaux sa mission de surveillance
et de protection du public
peu après le barreau s'est rendu à
lac-mégantic rencontré des victimes du
stratagème madame prémont déplore que
personne n'est porté plainte
malheureusement aucun citoyen qui ont
communiqué avec le barreau peau vraiment
leur donner un fils d'événements ou
voilà comment ça s'est passé voilà ce
que je considère être incorrectes
même sans avoir reçu de plainte
le barreau peut agir et devrait le faire
estime anthony bata spécialiste en droit
disciplinaire pour moi il ya quelque
chose à ce niveau là qui est
questionnable qui mérite d'être enquête
et définitive
le barreau a tous les pouvoirs pour
enquêter et les faits ici soulève
amplement de question pour le justifier
à son avis ce qui m'interpelle beaucoup
c'est cette approche auprès d'une
clientèle est très vulnérable
je ne vois aucune urgence d'approché de
solliciter ces personnes là pour faire
affaire avec qui que ce soit là que ce
soit une firme canadienne américaine et
japonaise
si le barreau mènent une telle enquête
c'est confidentiel mais à ce jour il n'a
contacté aucune des victimes qui ont
témoigné publiquement
l'avocat hans mercier n'a jamais caché
avoir rapidement encourager les victimes
à faire affaire avec la firme
controversée des garcia
vous les avez encouragé à signer avec
ces firmes d'avocats qui vous avait
contacté et ça j'ai cru la firme garcia
volontairement ou non m mercier a
facilité le travail de cabinet douteux
en agissant auprès d'eux à titre de
conseiller va falloir se pencher sur ce
qui s'est passé exactement
savoir ce que ce que l'avocat québécois
pu poser comme jesse dee comme paroles
mais
il va de soi que s'il encourage ce type
de pratique là pour moi ça choque
l'honneur la dignité de la profession
anti mercier a toujours nié connaître le
passé de chasseur d'ambulances de garcia
mais qu'en est il vraiment
[Musique]
l'avocat hans mercier a paru surpris
lorsque nous l'avons confronté au fait
que willy garcia serait un chasseur
d'ambulances notoire aux états unis
rappelez-vous ce long silence
inconfortable c'est quelqu'un qui
recrutent des victimes d'accidents et
qui va les corps des avocats
notez que c'est illégal c'est ce qu'on
appelle aux états unis du barétous et
l'écouté des reproches que j'entends
pour la première fois contrairement à ce
qu'il affirmait à enquête
heintz mercier était apparemment courant
de ces reproches nous avons appris qu'il
aurait confirmé à au moins deux témoins
avoir toujours su que oui les garcia
était présent à lac mégantic et le rôle
qu'il jouait à ce jour son unique
commentaire se trouvent sur sa page
facebook où il qualifie le reportage d'
enquête de fake news m mercier est connu
dans le milieu juridique pour sa défense
des acériculteurs une cause qui la
portait jusqu'en cour suprême
il estime avoir aidé les victimes de lac
mégantic à obtenir justice avec des
compensations sans précédent en droit
canadien
selon ce qui apparaît sur le site du
parti 51 qui l'a relancé et dont il est
le chef le véritable choix c'est le
parti 51 le parti prendre l'annexion du
québec aux états-unis double pour un
québec dr grandir y faire une différence
dans le monde une réelle solution existe
devenir un état souverain membre de
l'union des états unis d'amérique
justement aux états unis les choses
bougent
deux des trois cabinets impliqués
webster et garcia font maintenant
l'objet d'une enquête par l'autorité
réglementaire des assureurs au texas
c'est grâce à michel whitmore la
spécialiste en indemnisation qui a
dénoncé sur nos ondes
l'intention des avocats américains de se
partager illégalement une commission sur
les produits financiers offerts aux
victimes ont été très clairs sur le fait
qu'il s'attendait à être payé pour ce
travail il m'a dit tu sais c'est comme
ça que je fais mon argent c'était
tellement flagrant et d'une telle
avidité
j'étais dégoûté
on attend toujours l'issue de cette
enquête
entre temps ici au québec le barreau
reste discret sur ses intentions de
poursuivre ou non
willy garcia pour exercice illégal de la
profession
si rien n'est fait pour stopper le
stratagème de garcia le chasseur
d'ambulances pourrait continuer
d'empocher de l'argent destiné aux
victimes de lac mégantic
car il reste encore 20 millions à verser
en indemnités d'ici la fin de l'année
dont cinq millions aux endeuillés la
firme comptable recteur qui gère le
fonds est impuissante empêcher garcia
d'obtenir encore une fois sa part des
honoraires
même si ça nous tracasse c'est compliqué
note de cet aspect dos des ententes qui
ont été prises en les les famines de lac
mégantic et les avocats américains
exactement qu'est ce qui vaut à qui au
niveau des honoraires on ne sait pas ni
lecture donc ni le barreau ni le
gouvernement pourtant préoccupé par la
situation ne peuvent intervenir pour
empêcher que l'argent durement amassés
pour aider les victimes ne finissent
entre les mains de cabinet d'avocats
douteux
sans témoignage la preuve est difficile
à faire
anthony batta l'expert en déontologie
n'est pas surpris que les endeuillés de
lac-mégantic soient réticents à se
manifester
est-ce que vous pouvez comprendre que
ces gens alors porte pas plainte
absolument comme je peux comprendre que
des victimes d'agressions sexuelles ou
des victimes de tout type de dommage je
peux parfaitement comprendre pourquoi
ils ne veulent pas aller de l'avant
ça peut paraître rigide metz c'est juste
écouter je comprends votre propos je
comprends parfaitement votre propos
cette injustice lol à mes yeux est
magnifique les familles des victimes se
sentent encore une fois laissée à
elle-même pour livrer la bataille
[Musique]
on est de retour et en quête sylvie on
vient de voir votre partager les gens à
peu se pose une question pourquoi les
gens ne portent pas plainte
il ya probablement plusieurs réponses à
cette question rappelez vous la santé
publique rapporte beaucoup de détresse
psychologique encore et il ya des gens
qui ont besoin de tourner la page tout
simplement s'il lui est pas aussi
quelque chose d'un peu délicat avec
l'argent est un puits sans tabou autour
de l'argent et ce n'est pas unique à la
tragédie de lac mégantic
il ya des gens qui nous ont confié se
faire aborder dans la rue sert dire
qu'ils sont riches maintenant alors
c'est très difficile pour les endeuillés
de reprendre de nouvelles démarches
même si ça n'implique pas d'argent parce
que malheureusement ils ont peur d'être
jugé c'est parfaitement compréhensible
et on espère que les choses vont avancer
pour eux et c'est déjà tout pour cette
semaine au nom de toute l'équipe
on vous remercie d'avoir été là revenus
nous la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]